[Applaudissements]
si vous vous demandez depuis le début de
la soirée
pourquoi on vous a fait parvenir une
médaille en chocolat chacun vous allez
bientôt le découvrir
mais d'abord je vais vous raconter une
vieille histoire familiale
c'est une histoire qui remonte à
longtemps
non vraiment très longtemps l'un de mes
aïeux avaient pour habitude de se rendre
à la ville la plus proche et c'était son
cousin hubert qui l'y amener en
charrette un jour
hubert lui fit part d'une rumeur
persistante au village la terre serait
ronde
mon ancêtre tout chamboulé par cette
idée mais n'ayant aucun moyen de
vérifier les dires de cousins hubert dû
se résoudre à le croire sur parole
quelques siècles plus tard je me suis à
mon tour trouvait dans une situation
étrangement similaires lors d'un trajet
en hummer mon chauffeur m'a dit être
persuadés que la terre était plate
en bon physicien il m'est facile d'avoir
un esprit pour le moins critique
vis-à-vis de cette affirmation
mais même si je n'avais pas été j'aurais
pu contrairement à mon ancêtre vérifier
son propos en effet entre cousins hubert
et chauffeurs hubert nous sommes passés
par un data bang autrement dit une
quantité astronomique de données est
désormais accessible à tous et en
particulier concernant la rotondité de
la terre nous avons virtuellement tous
accès à la somme de toutes la
connaissance humaine mais s'est donné
toutes accessibles qu'elles sont
suffisantes elle réellement à la
reconstruction des connaissances voire à
la construction de nouveaux savoirs
prenons un exemple très concret en tant
que physicien
je reconnais qu'il m'arrive de rêver au
prix nobel et vous connaissez les jeunes
j'ai décidé de fouiller un petit peu
internet à la recherche de conseils pour
améliorer mes chances d'en obtenir un et
figurez vous que j'ai trouvé il suffit
tout simplement que je mange plus de
chocolat voyez par vous même
j'ai ici le nombre de prix nobel par
million d'habitants dans certains pays
et j'ai également la consommation
annuelle en chocolat dans ces mêmes pays
et vous voyez clairement que plus l'on
mange de chocolat plus on a de chances
de gagner le prix nobel
voyez en revenant à td que saclay ce
soir vous augmentez vos chances de
remporter la médaille nobel alors je
l'espère grâce aux intervenants
mais déjà en repartant avec la médaille
en chocolat que vous trouverez dans
votre sac
bon je suis d'accord avec vous c'est un
peu farfelue peut-être que le chocolat a
un impact sur nos capacités cognitives
mais on voit mal comment il pourrait à
lui seul augmenter sensiblement les
chances de gagner le prix nobel
en fait on dit que ces deux grandeurs la
consommation de chocolat et le nombre de
prix nobel sont corrélés c'est à dire
que leurs évolutions sont semblables en
revanche cela ne veut pas nécessairement
dire qu'elles sont reliés causalement ce
que montre cet exemple c'est qu'il est
assez facile de se laisser abuser par
des allures de graphiques de faire dire
ce que l'on veut aux données et d'en
tirer des conclusions
n'ayant pas lieu d'être pourtant
l'article qui contenait l'étude initiale
de cette corrélation amusante mais tu
est justement en garde contre les
conclusions hâtives en fait des données
brutes tels que je viens de prendre dans
cet exemple fournissent finalement des
informations assez limité pour la bonne
et simple raison que ces données ne sont
pas du tout structuré ni contextualiser
visualiser de simple corrélation apporte
peu c'était établir des relations
causales entre événement une hiérarchie
une structure globale qui présente un
réel intérêt
et là c'est une autre paire de manches
car comme vous le savez la quantité de
données est colossal rendez vous compte
nous produisons chacun une quantité de
données de l'ordre de quelques
mégaoctets par minute
c'est l'équivalent d'un tome de harry
potter rempli 2-0 et devant que l' on
écrirait chacun chaque minute ces
données que nous produisons en cette
quantité absolument faramineuses rendent
le fait d'établir des relations causales
particulièrement complexe et du coup ça
rend le fait de réussir un à cette fois
restructuré ces données un domaine qui
est réservé est quasiment uniquement aux
experts et si on pousse le raisonnement
un cran plus loin
le fait de déléguer cette compréhension
ce traitement des données
ça fait apparaître un point majeur celui
de la confiance
comme vous le savez surtout si cela
touche de près ou de loin à notre vie la
confiance est un sujet extrêmement
sensible et c'est une chose fragile qui
a tôt fait de se transformer en défiance
et ce même sur des sujets bien moins
polémique comme on l'a vu avec la terre
plate c'est ce qui s'est passé dans
l'esprit de mon chauffeur hubert que ce
soit via des discussions entre amis des
blogs ou des vidéos en ligne il a tourné
le dos à ce que des siècles de sciences
ont permis d'affirmer de manière
absolument certaine et qu'il a appris à
l'école
j'ai donc décidé de faire moi même le
test j'ai regardé un certain nombre de
ces vidéos complotistes
j'ai remarqué qu'elle présentait toutes
un point commun ces vidéos vous et que
vous exhorte à ne pas vous laisser
manipuler et à devenir vous même
des chercheurs de vérité mais cette
recherche de vérité qui peut paraître
valorisante
aux yeux des spectateurs de ces vidéos
revient en fait simplement à accorder
une confiance aveugle dans l'auteur de
ces propos
or c'est tout l'inversé de ce que fait
la science la science ne fait pas appel
à la croyance
elle n'a pas besoin de vous demander de
lui faire confiance puisqu'elle fournit
d'elle-même des preuves vérifiables
alors bien sûr dans notre vie on ne peut
pas passer notre temps à vérifier toutes
les informations qui nous parviennent et
on doit bien à un moment où à un autre
faire confiance bien mais à qui faire
confiance aux scientifiques
d'aucuns rétorqueront et on ne pourra
pas leur donner complètement tort que
l'on ne saurait non plus accorder une
confiance aveugle aux scientifiques ils
citeront par exemple des scandales
sanitaires ou des conflits d'intérêts
ont dévoyé la parole scientifique
j'insiste donc sur un point je ne vous
dis pas de me faire confiance à moi
scientifique au contraire ne me fait
surtout pas confiance et ne fait même
pas confiance à lui pourquoi parce qu'un
scientifique
un chercheur en tant qu'individu et
corruptible un groupe de chercheurs et
corruptible mais la science la recherche
en tant que somme de toutes les
contributions des chercheurs est
incorruptible
malheureusement aujourd'hui des
imposteurs et complotistes joue souvent
sur ce terrain là et se cachent derrière
un opaque jargon pseudo scientifiques
qui leur fait gagner en crédibilité
auprès du grand public
comment alors distinguer la science de
la pseudo-science un bon premier critère
c'est l'étude des sources utilisées
prenons un exemple volontairement pointu
peut-être avez-vous déjà entendu parler
de l'observation en 2012 du boson de
higgs qui a été annoncé dans cet article
cette publication majeure a été à dire
si t'es pas moins de 140 publication
d'auteurs différents et même l'article
qui a prédit l'un des articles qui a
prédit dans les années 60 déjà
l'existence de ce boson reposer sur les
connaissances scientifiques à l'époque
mais prenons à présent un autre article
de 2012 qui traite également du boson de
higgs et qui aux yeux d'un non
spécialistes seraient jugés au moins
aussi sérieux que les deux précédents
mais arrêtons-nous un instant sur sa
liste de citation
un seul et même nom revient en boucle
c'est pas n'importe lequel c'est celui
de l'auteur de cet article
étrange en fait les publications ses
relais des théories douteuses se re cite
souvent mot pour mot ce qui réduit leur
apparente abondant de l'abondance de
sources à une seule et même source
copié et recopié à l'infini et elle peut
même comme dans notre exemple reposer
exclusivement sur les élucubrations de
leurs auteurs au contraire la communauté
scientifique et parfois durement jugée
par la population à cause de l'existence
de théories contradictoires ou
divergentes qui apparaissent dans son
sein et en effet cette apparente absence
de consensus a de quoi désarçonner
mais en fait c'est exactement ce qui
fait que l'on peut faire confiance à la
science en général
cette pluralité de théorie et de source
est extrêmement saine et contribuent
directement au progrès scientifique
chaque contribution individuelle d'un
chercheur et testé par d'autres
chercheurs confirmés améliorer
contredite et ainsi de suite
c'est en étant contredits que l'on a vu
de son raisonnement
cette théorie est que l'on finit par
atteindre un consensus
ainsi en s'appuyant sur ce socle
entremêlées qui représente la
connaissance scientifique actuelle les
chercheurs construisent le progrès alors
je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà vu des
fourmis construire un pont pour
traverser un précipice je vous propose
de les observer un instant
c'est fascinant elle s'organise en une
sorte de pyramide vivante formant une
base solide afin de permettre à quelques
fourmis d'atteindre l'autre côté du
gouffre c'est une belle métaphore de la
recherche et du progrès les chercheurs
s'appuient sur leurs prédécesseurs pour
tâtonner toujours un peu plus loin
atteindre un nouveau rivage et faire
bénéficier la société entière d'un
nouveau pro
oui si je suis là ce soir c'est
justement parce que j'ai décidé de
m'engager en tant que chercheur et en
tant qu'entrepreneur le data bang a fait
apparaître deux défi extrêmement
complexe à résoudre et a relevé le
premier il nous faut aujourd'hui une
innovation ambitieuse de rupture pour
valoriser ces données mais il faut
également restructurer la transmission
de la connaissance afin de restaurer la
confiance en la science
or je pense que les chercheurs sont plus
que n'importe qui capable de relever ces
deux défis
d'abord l'innovation et l'adn de leur
métier ils ont la tournure d'esprit pour
concevoir de nouveaux modèles et
développer de nouvelles techniques
de plus ils sont les premiers maillons
d'une chaîne de transmission de la
connaissance qu'ils participent de même
à élaborer alors bien sûr les chercheurs
contribue déjà à l'innovation parfois
très en amont en ce qui concerne la
recherche fondamentale
il contribue également à la transmission
du savoir en enseignant mais soyons
beaucoup plus ambitieux que cela nous
chercheurs devons pouvoir nous engager
beaucoup plus dans la vie de la société
je lance donc un triple appel ce soir
d'abord à mes collègues chercheurs il
est de notre devoir de faire bénéficier
la société de notre expertise de prendre
position pour défendre la connaissance
et de ne pas laisser l'obscurantisme
digital prendre encore plus d'ampleur
ensuite aux acteurs du secteur privé
malgré les différences culturelles qui
nous séparent encore long nous avons
beaucoup à nous apporter mutuellement et
nous chercheurs sommes de plus en plus
prêts à le faire et enfin à nous tous
soyons curieux posons des questions et
n'oublions pas que comme les fourmis
nous avons besoin de confiance et
d'entre aide pour franchir les obstacles
d'aujourd'hui et relever tous ensemble
les défis de demain merci
[Applaudissements]